let's tell about your experience of
making the film what did you enjoy about
the period of the sixties and doing the
accent as well I loved making this film
because I've always had a huge crush on
England like really truly and this felt
sort of like going to the prom with
England making this film it's so British
and I'm I loved the accent I mean as an
australian we have to know how to talk
like other people because it's just as
we're very far away also the period has
always been something that i think
especially with my age really fascinated
with it is our parents generation so
it's the things that we get told about
when we're children you know my mother
used to tell me about the ironing of the
hair and the and the shrinking jeans etc
so it's sort of something that is like
it's like fairytales when you were
growing up it was wonderful how did you
enjoy wearing those clothes and I loved
them I wanted to take them all home but
they all get wheeled away into a sort of
Indiana Jones vault to never be seen
again
you